hey everyone bandit here
it is early
i was going to record a playthrough for
bandit plays but then nintendo decided
to just drop this new trailer for
metroid dread and
it is good okay it is good so i'm gonna
break it down unfortunately i don't have
my reaction recorded i already saw it
but i'm going to break it down piece by
piece and we're going to talk about all
the things that i could see in this
trailer and hopefully if i miss anything
you guys are going to tell me in the
comments below
alright so
that made me jump a little bit the first
thing that happens obviously is samus
walks into this mysterious room now the
room itself can't be explained currently
because clearly it's on the unknown
planet that she has traveled to in
metroid dread but you can see on the
wall behind her there are these red
glowing circles you might be like oh
what the heck is a red glowing circle
well it is typical of chozo architecture
this hunch right here is confirmed
because when samus sees something in the
dens in the distance excuse me draws her
weapon then you can see she's actually
facing a giant chozo warrior just
standing there and as you can see the
red circles are present here too so it
appears to be this entire facility that
she's in is of chozo origin got some
trees in the background some pretty
stuff this really epic bridge over a
body of water this is a really epic
scene reminds me of the elden bridge and
twilight princess
so samus is approaching she's hostile at
first because honestly the guy looks
kind of uh kind of intimidating i don't
blame her and he's just staring her down
and here the chozo is in all its glory
so as you can see this chozo is actually
standing here in a chozo power suit
which as i'm sure you know is the same
kind of suit that samus wears which is
chozo in origin that explains the fact
that he has his own arm cannon and his
own uh power armor but he looks as
though he is of some notable chozo
status because look at these epic
tassels that are coming down from his
shoulder pads so he's just staring her
he's just staring her down and then he
jump scares everybody and then it
reveals that this is the dude this is
the person from these hieroglyphics that
we've been able to see in each of the
trailers until now you can see it is him
because he's a chozo and he's got the
power armor and he's also giant assuming
that these others here are about sam's
size now what's disturbing about these
hieroglyphics here is you can see that
these are allegedly chozo warriors being
commanded by big chozo person and they
are throwing these individuals down into
this bottomless pit probably to their
deaths and if you look closely at these
individuals guess who they are they're
chozo this is a chozo civil war led by
this individual and you know what we
actually know who this guy is so slight
spoilers for samus ii or i'm sorry i
think the remake is the one that added
this little detail in but let me do a
little bit of research to make sure i'm
correct real quick okay yes i did
remember it correctly as of samus
returns so that is the remake of metroid
2 there was an added memory that
showcased an unknown chozo warrior
commanding other warriors to murder the
chozos who were involved with the
creation of the metroids which is a
whole other piece of metroid history
which there are plenty of videos
covering on the web about but guys do
you see it this person right here with
the cape and the arm cannon and giant
stature
this is them this is the one that
murdered the other chozo and this
hieroglyph is a depiction of it i don't
know why i didn't put that together
previously but it's blowing my mind
anyway let's continue on all right got
some gameplay snippets here some good
stuff if you pause the screen at this
point right here you can see that there
are actually what appears to be uh chozo
constructs that samus is going to be
fighting
you got a little bit of a better angle
right here you can more clearly see the
arm cannon uh the power armor the beak
it all just kind of adds up and now it
makes sense because the evil murderous
chozo was behind it and then it just
keeps cutting back and forth between
their fight here as you can see uh the
evil chozo does fire at samus with the
giant arm cannon
that's a powerful cannon
and then it jumps at sam as we get this
glorious shot of it in the air complete
with the claw feed and claws on the
hands
and then we immediately changed to samus
in my favorite shot of the entire
trailer the return of crade like
i don't even know what's going on here
i'm assuming that he was resurrected
clearly but we can see a couple things
in this scene besides samus just being
an absolute unit just staring at him not
even flinching
i'm gonna have to contain myself as we
can see craig here is actually chained
up chained up that automatically implies
that the powers that be are not space
pirates
just like everything else in this entire
facility craid has been put here by the
evil chozo who resurrected him for
i don't know possibly uh as a weapon
probably but yet has him here because
they weren't going to use him just yet
and this is sam was just like oh man
here we go again so absolutely stellar
reveal mind-blowing some more shots of
gameplay some cool underwater fights
samus has her jumps back
uh more false stuff and you can actually
see it better in another shot too
uh it's purple purple and green so the
gravity suit is back i believe the
website said that as you can guess her
upgrades have all been removed so we're
probably going to be doing the same
thing that we've done in all the
previous metroid games and we're going
to be starting from ground zero and then
we're going to be going through the
facility and finding these upgrades so
really cool to see that the gravity suit
does make a comeback more shots of samus
fighting the evil chozo he's got some
sort of really cool shield just so cool
just walking while just staring her down
and then he just rushes her but she
deflects it and is able to actually
avoid damage which is really really cool
it's cool to see that this clearly final
boss type person right here is being
fought pretty evenly by samus i mean
she's holding her own
very cool to see the grapple making a
return that was always a really cool
mechanic
this is just some more shots of how you
can use the grapple in the game and this
is a really cool scene it appears to me
that these are some sort of tracking
devices like cameras potentially um
chozo in origin and because samus is
walking around in clearly a chozo area
with the statue right here she's walking
around in the complete darkness i think
she was trying to stealth through here
but this clearly means that things are
not going her way and she's been
discovered perhaps this is what leads to
her encounter with the big guy
she's got some really cool new like
homing missiles
very very cool
extremely cool actually
okay and then as you can see she blasts
this guy in the face with a super
missile the missile was green it was a
super missile he tanks it and is largely
undamaged but i do like that they added
this in here because it shows that he is
not invincible okay a super missile
cracked his armor but ultimately just
kind of served to piss him off
he rushes samus who does not deflect it
because he rushed her so quickly and
then things are looking really bad for
samus he has her and i like the scene
because it just shows the sheer size
difference between them i mean this is a
warrior alright this is a warrior of
high esteem and high high deadliness to
manhandle v samus like this and because
she has all of her upgrades here which
we can presume by the coloring of her
armor and the super missiles
most people are assuming that this is
actually the start of the game this is
who she fights and she's going to
survive this encounter but she's going
to survive it with ability amnesia so
she's going to forget how to use her
abilities so this scene is really cool
because at first it implies a little bit
of the struggle that we were talking
about with the chozo anchoza war we've
got broken pillars everywhere we've got
spears so weaponry we've got the chozo
tassels in the back but you can see
right here that clearly the camera is
looking at and is about to
reanimate
a torizo which is an animated chozo
statue like a war statue they're meant
to defend things normally in the game
samus has to kill them and then she gets
like an upgrade or something and right
after this we do see that it comes
straight to life and it looks like this
one is going to be
very very deadly flipping around the
place with one of these spears but you
know nothing that our our leading lady
cannot take care of a little bit more
gameplay we've got the awesome jump
coming back we've got the gravity suit
coming back we've got the sprint coming
back we've got her screw attack coming
back we've got some deadly enemies that
are going gonna be attacking samus at
the same time
and then it cuts back to the fight
between samus and the big chozo you can
see this is clearly after she shot him
in the face because of the crack right
here and he's holding her up in his left
hand and he's got his cannon pointed at
her face and he's charging up a deadly
shot we have this little really
frightening shot of samus just staring
at what looks to be her incoming doom
with dread in her eyes
and then it cuts back to her fighting
with crade now craig's nasty alright but
he looks to be nastier than ever in
glorious hd this is probably a sword
that you have to i don't know go into
and blow him up or something with the
morph ball for him i don't know he looks
nasty but due to samus's suit here i'm
assuming that this takes place actually
before uh the big bad chozo because she
still has all her upgrades here either
that or it's at the end
so she runs up there you can see again
that he is clearly restrained not ready
to be used again i'm assuming but other
than that though he looks largely the
same
he doesn't look like a meta ridley or a
meta crate or anything like that it
looks like he's just biologically the
same individual just resurrected or
maybe recreated she rushes up presumably
kicks his butt you can see the gravity
suit again in full glory right here as
she's deflecting another enemy and the
room she's standing in looks like some
sort of chamber where creatures were
being created but they don't appear to
be metroid's at first glance my memory
is a little fuzzy as far as what the
different stages of metroid are but as
far as we know metroid's are extinct
okay so tbd on what that is in that
chamber right there we cut to what looks
like sam is fighting another torizo
because clearly it's chozo in origin
this torzo is just lunging at her she
smacks it in the face looks to be maybe
possessed by some sort of black goopy
substance there's definitely something
more going on here couldn't be the sax
right
no
no it couldn't be could it it could be
so samus was sent out here to
investigate the rediscovery of the sax
virus right
who knows i don't know how it would have
survived but it would be able to possess
the statues and make them contort like
this
but nothing samus can't deal with and we
cut back to this face full of arm cannon
that she's staring down it's charging up
she's looking real dreadful he's looking
real dreadful
he says something in chozo it sounds
really terrifying probably like die now
or something like that
and she's looking like she's gonna clock
out before he even shoots her but then
this happens
she
surges with some sort of power so
beforehand look it's all it looks normal
it's green glowing with uh the normal
power of her suit
but then it immediately turns to the
same color that he has
you saw that right and then a heartbeat
and then after this we just have the
logos but now of course we have the evil
chozo behind her in the logos let me
just let me just take a second and just
appreciate how beautiful that looks just
new backgrounds all around new
backgrounds all around but the last
thing i wanted to point out which is the
last thing that we can tell from this
trailer is that this power that she now
seems to be surging with same as him
it's like a pinkish glow and he even
balls up a pinkish ability in his hand
every time that he blasts with energy
it's this pinkish energy glow
and so whatever that energy is it is now
possessing her and clearly this is what
leads to her ability amnesia that the
website was alluding to anyway guys that
is my first reaction
breakdown analysis of this trailer let
me know what you think let me know if
you learned anything and let me know uh
more importantly if i missed anything
because i am super hyped if you can't
tell and i know a lot of you out there
are too but anyway that's it for this
quick uh impromptu video here be sure to
like this video if you enjoyed it
subscribe to stick around for a lot more
nintendo stuff to come and have a great
rest of your day this is bandit looking
forward to seeing you in the next one
and signing out peace
[Music]
you